what a Sunday night I just had watching
dr. sleep oh my god I mean I was saying
like I don't really get scared watching
movies but watching Rebecca Ferguson
especially there's like a fear that you
feel watching her she approached that
character in a way I thought was genius
which was that you know I'm looking at
Rose the hat saying this is one of the
best antagonists I've seen in the King
book in a very long time and she's
looking at these horrible things she has
to do in the movie and trying to figure
out how to do them and she talked to me
in prep and said you know I think the
way through this is I have to just
decide she's not the monster of the
movie she's the hero of the story and
she's doing these horrible things to
protect her family and the monsters are
Dan and amber who show up and tried to
kill her family right and once she'd
rationalized all these things it made
the performance I think so much more
chilling like the charm where it's like
I you love her love her yeah yeah can
you talk a little bit your history with
Stephen King I know you're a big fan
yeah go from reading him as a as a as a
kid yeah I started reading Stephen King
way way before I was old enough to read
Stephen King and it completely shaped
kind of everything I I think about what
the genre can do what horror fiction
should do the importance of character
kind of this this worldview that sees
the world is this very dark and
treacherous dangerous place full of
mystery but that also has a
counterbalance to that can kind of show
ordinary people at their best and and so
yeah Stephen King has been my hero since
I was a kid this is the second time I've
been lucky enough to kind of play in his
sandbox right yeah so you're like you
know doing interviews beside him he's 12
support of this film also crazy what
does that mean to you oh it's it's it's
I still make the same weird noise
whenever it happens because I follow him
on Twitter and I'll just look down and
see something kind of pop up in my feet
yeah and I'll just make just like your
name yeah yeah it's it's it's it's still
completely surreal and you know I I'm a
fan first before before I was ever able
to make films
you know which I'm still everyday I'm
just lucky that that's the way my life
worked out mmm I spent you know my whole
life just being a rabid fan and so I
react that way first you know well he
liked pretty infamously
dunked on the shining movie yes so what
kind of conversations did you two have
because you're kind of combining both of
those elements of his work and the
Kubrick film which I knew would be a
really tough sell for him yeah
in the beginning when when we were
developing the script you know I said
well this is what I think I should do I
think there's only one way to make this
movie and that's to acknowledge kind of
the cinematic impact of Kubrick's film
that's the language that everybody knows
when they think of the overlooked in the
Torrance's this could be a real chance
to celebrate that but it also could be a
really wonderful opportunity to take
those two visions which you know still
to this day is something that he has
very strong feelings about and try to
bring them back together a little bit
try to reconcile them even even if only
a little and that is as a fan was was a
an irresistible opportunity he after he
kind of heard me out and heard how I
would approach it and why I wanted to do
it that way he gave His blessing to do
that before I went to write the script
and if he hadn't given me his blessing I
wouldn't made the film did you do
high-pitched noise yeah then then I just
started making this kind of strangled
stressed-out noise yeah and that has
lasted every day kind of up to now
really I mean I can imagine I mean
there's there's certain elements where I
was like I mean it can't it's got to be
a lot of pressure to kind of recast the
Shelley Duvall Jack Nicholson roles and
have people in there it's been the most
intimidating project and and for actors
you know like Alex Esso who plays Wendy
and Carl Laemmle a place to calor and
you know the pressure on them to you
know there was a sense with all of us
that like oh my god we're stepping into
these monolithic shadows and
any move we make is going to be
scrutinized and every decision is going
to be triple guessed we have to be
really as respectful as possible and we
all looked at this as a celebration of
the shining yeah and a sequel you know
that I've loved to look at it as a
descendants in meted it has the DNA of
its parents you know and the parents are
Kubrick thinking yeah it still has to
kind of find its own identity and we all
look at it that way
did you use any footage from the
original shine air where are you
recreating pretty much there are three
shots that are Kubrick's shots the shot
of the island and the canyon and the two
shots after with the car driving up the
mountain okay
those are his shots we changed him to
nighttime and added snow and we changed
out the car but all the rest is
recreation so did you redo the blood
elevator yes Wow yes so when the teaser
trailer came out because someone had
asked and I said actually that's the
only shot in the teaser trailer that
that is Kubrick's at the time it was
because ours wasn't finished Wow
but now it has been finished and the the
elevator shot that's in the film is ours
[Music]